- [Narrator] These are nachos.
Golden crispy chips, gooey melted cheese,
mounds of toppings galore.
They are delicious.
They're named after a man,
a man named Nacho.
This was Ignacio Anaya,
known to friends and foes alike as Nacho.
In 1943, Ignacio was a
maître d' at this restaurant,
The Old Victory Club, in
Piedras Negras, Mexico,
a border town a jalapeño's throw
from Eagle Pass, Texas,
home of Fort Duncan,
an army base filled with
military men and families.
One day, a group of army
wives crossed the border,
they shopped, they got hungry,
they went to The Victory Club.
The chef wasn't there.
But Ignacio, maître d', didn't
want to turn the women away,
so he sprang into action.
Grabbing tortillas,
shredded cheddar cheese
and jalapeños, he put his
creation into the oven.
Pensively, he served it to the army wives.
They loved it.
Returning to Texas, they spread
the el evangelio del nacho,
the gospel of the nacho.
Nachos especialios became
so adored and renowned
Ignacio opened up his own restaurant,
the creatively named Nacho's Restaurante.